la anemia de células falciformes es una
enfermedad sanguínea hereditaria que
afecta a los glóbulos rojos en esta
enfermedad una molécula proteica anormal
llamada hemoglobina s cambia sus
glóbulos rojos flexibles con forma de
disco por células rígidas con forma de
hoz
las células falciformes pueden bloquear
el flujo sanguíneo y esto puede causar
dolor y daños en los tejidos las células
falciformes no duran tanto como los
glóbulos rojos normales
debido a esto su sangre tiene menos
glóbulos rojos de lo normal esta
afección se llama anemia las opciones de
tratamiento para la anemia falciforme
pueden incluir medicamentos o
procedimientos para ayudar a aliviar los
síntomas o en ciertos casos un
trasplante de células madre
hematopoyéticas para curar
potencialmente la enfermedad
los antibióticos y las vacunas contra
las enfermedades pueden ayudar a
prevenir las infecciones su proveedor de
atención médica puede aconsejarle tomar
analgésicos para el dolor intenso o
crónico el medicamento más comúnmente
prescrito para el dolor se llama hidroxi
urea y ayuda a reducir el dolor al
prevenir el daño a los glóbulos rojos
también reduce el riesgo de
complicaciones a largo plazo
otros medicamentos prescritos que ayudan
a prevenir complicaciones y a mejorar
los resultados a largo plazo
sonrisan lisumap boxelotor y L glutamina
si tiene un episodio de dolor muy
intenso es posible que se le practique
un procedimiento llamado Transfusión de
sangre esto sustituye las células
falciformes por glóbulos rojos sanos
para los pacientes jóvenes que tienen o
corren el riesgo de sufrir
complicaciones debido a la anemia
falciforme se puede recomendar un
trasplante de células madre
hematopoyéticas esto puede curar a
algunas personas que padecen esta
enfermedad antes del trasplante es
posible que se le administran fármacos
de quimioterapia radioterapia o ambos
esto destruirá las células madre
anormales que forman la sangre en su
médula ósea
luego recibirás células madre sanas
procedentes de la médula ósea o de la
sangre de un donante el donante suele
ser un integrante de la familia cuyo
tipo de tejido es muy parecido al suyo
las células madre sanas que forman la
sangre del donante viajarán a través de
su sangre hasta su médula ósea donde
fabricarán glóbulos rojos normales en
lugar de células falciformes
para conocer más tratamientos para la
anemia de células falciformes hable con
su proveedor de atención médica